oui
[Musique]
je t'ai cherché je visais la lune
tu m'as connu le coeur dans la brume
quand l'amour à déserter mon île j'ai
écrit entre le marteau et l'enclume
ma seule richesse ma famille n'est
coutume j'ai fait lors dans mes disques
et m'a plu mais tu seras éternel dans
mes projets poussé me
pourtant dur mais les yeux et vasiljevs
et on mangeait fait pas souvent mais pas
son miroir je ne vois qu'un enfant
je vais plus qui même qui m'a vite clos
restera-t-il avec le temps
[Musique]
je n'apprends pas assez grand pour toi
je ne
je la vends
thouars
tu m'as le malhonnête du m'allume ont
passé débute un jour de ruines
je marche entre les douilles l est
l'homme en algérie gérer d'être
rien en fait
mais jamais dans nos coeurs
les robes
chicken au milieu du salon
toi m'at il serait en vie mais j'aurais
pas ton espoir qui m'anime joran la
venue de sentiments j'aurais jamais
rencontré le père de mam
[Musique]
montant de son groupe et le sens je
t'aime rimmer
et
c'est mon coup droit
quoique toi
jean laurent
en
[Musique]
la lune est du mali
je me rends pas ses morts
[Musique]
chacun apporte une
mais bon
tous les erp
[Applaudissements]
toutefois dans ses mémoires